Kaitlyn and Shawn keep on getting it on  the bachelorette stars are engaged and  engaging in some major PDA they just  can't keep their hands off each other et  has pics of the pair out to eat in NYC  at a restaurant called catch and Shawn  literally catches Kaitlyn giving her a  piggyback ride outside and then grabbing  her head in his hands for a full-out  makeout sesh hey give the people what  they want right  Kaitlyn chose Shawn as her man Monday  night and told et this week she's almost  scared to wear her new super blingy  sparkler it scares me it scares the crap  out of me because I wear very  inexpensive things and it's just bizarre  to me we're pretty sure Shawn would  protect it just gonna keep staring at  those muscles oh and guess how they kept  close during the filming of the show he  like sprayed his favorite t-shirt with  his Cologne and gave it to me for my  pajamas well we'd rather just see it  with no shirt but whatever works  you